the day before my bar mitzvah I was
sitting in my rabbis office and I
started to cry it's not because I was
just afraid of the big day it's not
because I didn't know which girl I was
going to ask for the first dance at my
disco themed bar mitzvah party the next
night which was awesome because I had a
secret and tell if you understand a
little bit about what that felt like
think about the person you're sitting
next to either you're right or left
really look at them and imagine asking
them are you male or female you might
not need to ask that imagine asking
where are you from you know what's your
nationality what's your background now
ask that person do you believe in God
that's probably going to be a little
harder for you right and even as I am
talking about it here I'm afraid to talk
to you about this because I'm an atheist
and as I say that to you you form
probably some assumptions about what
that means but think about what I just
told you I told you what I don't believe
in not anything about what I do believe
in or what I do care about as a problem
with the word atheism but it's a bigger
problem than just the GSB or me feeling
awkward in front of you guys in the u.s.
there are seven states where atheists
are barred from holding a public office
by constitutional law in Arkansas
atheists are barred from being a witness
to a trial those are old laws and
impossible to enforce I hope but the
court of public opinion is no better
unfortunately about half of americans
say they would never vote for an atheist
for public office regardless of how well
qualified they work well that means to
me is like half of you guys wouldn't
vote for me because of my religious
preference or non religious preference
but
that's prejudice right and this climate
it it makes non-religious people in the
u.s. feel less American or unamerican
but fifteen percent of americans are
non-religious and that's not even
including the people who define
themselves as religious but also say
they don't believe in God it's like 45
million people in fact the
fastest-growing religious preference in
the u.s. is non-religious it's the only
one that's grown in all 50 states in the
past generation and what prejudices is
bad weather it seems a big group or a
small group this is my story and
religious prejudice is like a much
bigger issue than I can tackle but I can
talk to you about atheism because it's
what I've known sorry so this happens
because of a mistrust and I'm willing to
bet that those of you who are in the
room who are non-religious have felt
that mistrust in some point in your life
it's natural to assume if you drive your
your morals from God or from Scripture
that atheists have no morals but this is
not true so it's a big problem and to
help proposed like a solution I want to
take you back to my rabbis office so
there I am sitting across from him and
as I'm reading the Torah it's the scroll
I'm reading Hebrew which I knew for like
a month and then forgot and and I start
to cry and I say I I can't do this oh
you know I'm about to read this in front
of my family and my friends and I don't
believe it I don't believe in God and he
leans back he strokes his beard and and
he asked me two questions he said first
what did you learn from your Torah
portion which was the story of Abraham
Isaac Abraham and Isaac and then he
asked me if in 10 years you're driving
on Lakeshore Drive and you see a member
of your Hebrew school class on the side
of the road with a flat tire what will
you do
and I said oh I'd stop and change their
tire what he didn't know as I had just
learned to change a tire which to me was
like so exciting and like really my
passage into manhood like forget the bar
mitzvah stuff and and so he stood up out
of his chair and he reached his hand out
and he said Evan on behalf of the Jewish
community I welcome you and even though
and that was great right it made it made
me feel much better and I went through
that with the bar mitzvah but I want to
point out what he did there he didn't
take my lack of belief as an answer in
itself he pushed me he asked me what I
do believe in and he made sure that the
values i held matched up with those of
the community that he led and what it
did for me was i realized i can decide
this for myself i need to think about
what my beliefs really are I'm a
humanist a humanist takes to work a look
at the world around and sees that
innocent people are sometimes punished
the world is unjust and therefore there
is no competent moral management a
humanist says so you look at this
sometimes lousy world and think it's
then up to me I'm a superintendent of my
own life I it's up to me to solve human
problems even though I know I can never
fully complete that task what it means
to me in short is like I don't believe
in life after death so I believe that
this life is the one that matters and
the reason I say that specifically is
there's a misunderstanding about those
who don't believe in Heaven and Hell or
a judgment from on high and I want to
read you a quick quote from a pastor who
I actually quite respect there
represents or the other point of view
which is that if your time on earth
where all there is to this life I would
suggest you start living it up
immediately you could forget about being
good and ethical and you wouldn't have
to worry about any consequences of your
actions you can indulge yourself in
total self-centeredness because your
actions would have no long-term
consequences to point out what's wrong
with that and a pic on one of you give
do you believe in God if you decided
tomorrow for yourself that God didn't
exist and that there was no one judging
you would you go on a spree of raping
and pillaging I thought not but it's
like it's good to confirm what this mrs.
is that we evolved to help each other
and there's nothing more important to my
long-term happiness than the effect I
have on the people around me on you
unfortunately I you know I realized that
this this prejudice comes from a place
of just not knowing right when we don't
know something we fear it fear leads to
prejudice and the non-religious don't do
a great job of representing what we
stand for what we believe in because
it's this amorphous group of all kinds
of people I'm just one of them I don't
speak for the group but I felt this
prejudice when i was when i was 10 i
went to my friend andy's house a lot on
the weekends to play with legos he had
this like current-day lego set with a
train and I had the futuristic one with
the monorail and this Saturday I stayed
over and his family who are Catholic
took me to church which is really nice
and then after church we had waffles and
his mom had never talked to a Jewish
person before so she started asking me
questions about my religion which was
really cool but I had no idea I was
speaking behalf on all Jewish people of
all Jewish people right then sorry guys
she asked me as we're eating waffles do
you believe in God and I said no and she
said but surely you must believe in some
higher power and I'm like pouring serum
no and then and she said but heaven you
must have such a big head to not believe
that there's someone watching over you
someone someone guiding you you must be
so arrogant and that sounds pretty rough
but at the time I really was totally
focused on making sure there was maple
syrup in every little square of that
eggo waffle
so I wasn't upset by it but it's still
stuck with me and actually what I want
to show you is what I wish I could have
shown her at that time that sort of
represents the way I think about the
world there it is does anyone know what
this photo is it's really hard to see a
little bit closer no that's earth that
little dot this is this is a photo taken
by the Voyager spacecraft as it left our
solar system NASA had it turned around
one last time before was out of range
and take this photo so it's actually the
furthest away photo of Earth we have
earth is is that is the little dot
within the circle it's one pixel one
pale blue pixel and I look at this and I
think to myself I try to convince myself
that this pale blue dot and all that's
around it was created for one of the 10
million or so species of life on that
pale blue dot we're further that it was
created for one ethnic or religious
subdivision of that species I can't do
it for me this is another lesson that
science which I believe is the best way
we have to understand the world around
us is just the lesson after lesson in
humility we do not live in a privileged
reference frame our preferences don't
count therefore you are the custodian of
your own life's meeting so the next time
you meet someone who's an atheist
instead of starting from this blank
slate on which you might assume things
start from this I don't speak for other
people but it's a place to start and
more importantly when you meet someone
whose values differ from yours ask them
about it talk about it try to bridge
that gap and understand each other I
mean it's so important like my view of
the world impacts everything I do every
day but we don't talk about it so I want
to encourage you to think about that
person next to you again and actually
ask them what do you believe in thanks
you